There was a bit of a sort of second honeymoon
phase for Donald Trump early in the Corona
virus pandemic, and we talked about it at
the time, his approval rating on his handling
of the Corona virus pandemic was actually
not bad. Early on, his general presidential
approval had actually ticked up in mid-March
to close to 50 percent, which is very close
to a high for Donald Trump's presidency. And
this wasn't shocking. And as we talked about
at the time, there is this historical sort
of rally around the president tendency during
times of national crisis. We saw after 9/11,
for example, George W. Bush's approval spiked
dramatically to as high as 90 percent, which
is it's almost unthinkable today.
Of course, it was eventually squandered by
George W. Bush, but then it spiked again as
the Iraq war got going in early 2003, all
the way up to 71 percent approval. And then
again, that fell off for George W. Bush as
that war ended up being a completely misguided
disaster. And Donald Trump had a little bit
of this in March, back in March. His approval
ticked up. But as his as his administration's
response to the virus has tragically been
one of the worst in the world. I mean, I'm
not going to say the worst, but you have to
look pretty hard for leaders who responded
more poorly than Donald Trump did. We have
seen Donald Trump experience the sharpest
drop in approval of his presidency so far.
Now, the news here for now is the rapid change
so far. OK. The absolute numbers are still
in the normal range for Trump's presidency.
His approvals down to 43. That's not the absolute
low of his presidency. His disapproval spiked
to 54. Again, that's not the high disapproval
of his presidency. But if you're looking at
the chart with me right now, you see that
this is a very rapid nine point jump in disapproval
since the last time Gallup did the survey.
And a nine point jump in three weeks is the
biggest, fastest jump in that time period
during the presidency. Now, where will it
go next? We don't know, but it's clear that
Americans are on average realizing the disaster
that is Donald Trump handling a true crisis.
Now, his supporters are still absolutely enamored
with his handling. They now are increasingly
protesting for the reopening of states with
Trump increasingly supporting them. We'll
talk about that a little bit later. But at
the national level, on average, Trump's approval
has declined very quickly over the last three
weeks. Now, in the meantime, the polling for
Joe Biden in the 20 20 presidential election,
which is now just six and a half months away,
continues to be strong. But I'm going to keep
being very careful about this. All that I'm
telling you today is that right now, six and
a half months before the election, there is
a trend in which Joe Biden isn't doing poorly
against Donald Trump. The trend is that the
country is, as I said already, it's on average
a country that disapproves of Donald Trump
and is a country that on average is leaning
towards Joe Biden. But things can change quickly.
And remember that we have an electoral college
in the United States. So in the latest NBC
News Wall Street Journal poll, Biden is plus
seven over, Trump 49 to 42. That still leaves
a full 9 percent unsure or with third parties.
Right now, we then have a Harvard Harris poll,
which has Biden plus six. In this one, it's
Biden 53, Trump 47. That one has no undecideds.
Now, this could mean nothing by November and
Trump may get himself reelected. And so we
have to be very careful about inferring much
at all from this. Interesting. Also in North
Carolina, Biden is now plus one in a recent
poll. Trump had actually been winning in North
Carolina in a bunch of recent polls. So that's
a big flip. The caveat being this is a P P
P poll. P P P polls are known for leaning
Democratic. It may mean very little, but if
Biden can stay close in North Carolina, that's
a state that Trump won by three plus in 2016.
If it's even if Biden is really plus one in
North Carolina, that could set suggest a worse
outcome for Trump in 2020 than he had in 2016.
The important takeaways are we're counting
every vote. We're not opting out. I'm speaking
of optimistically. None of us are opting out
of the election. We're pushing for vote by
mail and the expansion of absentee ballots
so that we can keep people safe and voting
in November. Nothing changes for us as a result
of these numbers. We want no one to die or
go without corona virus care. You know, Republicans
are now trying to give some oxygen to this
theory that the left wants more people to
die from the virus so that it will be bad
for Donald Trump. Trump has already failed.
No one else needs to die for Trump to deserve
being removed in November. And I think that
that's the important thing that we have to
point out. Every time they say you want a
higher death toll, we say that's absolutely
ridiculous. There's no evidence of that. And
it's not about a higher death toll to justify
Trump's removal. Trump's rhetoric and actions
to date already justify his removal, even
if the deaths went to zero today. It's a false
premise. Don't let them trick you into these
red herrings, but also don't get lulled into
any sense of complacency because of these
numbers.